1943 tenía Apenas cuatro años cuando se
creó Pakistán mucha raf y su familia
hicieron parte del Éxodo masivo de
musulmanes de la India a la joven
Pakistán Allí se hizo soldado A los 18
años
27 años más tarde era ascendido a jefe
del ejército en 1999 el Primer Ministro
de la época intentó destituirlo el
ejército pero mediante un golpe de
estado no violento Pérez asumió
liderazgo de Pakistán y se convirtió
oficialmente en presidente en 2001 Bajo
su mando el estado experimentó un
periodo de crecimiento económico y de
acercamiento a los valores liberales en
un país de mayoría musulmana muy
conservador
después de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre en 2001 en Estados Unidos
declaró el apoyo de Pakistán a
Washington en la lucha contra al qaeda y
los talibanes afganos pa que estaban
ha tomado la decisión de formar parte de
una coalición con Estados Unidos para
luchar contra el terrorismo en todas sus
formas y donde quiera que exista
se convirtió así en un objetivo de
grupos radicales y se salvó de cuatro
intentos de asesinarlo
en 2007 ordenó un asalto a la mezquita
roja Isla mavad donde se encontraban
miembros de grupos fundamentalistas en
el que murieron 100 personas
en 2008 se le abrió un proceso de
destitución por haber impuesto el estado
de excepción y ordenar la dimisión de
jueces el jefe de estado dimite y se va
al exilio a Londres
cuatro años después
retorna intenta participar en elecciones
y es acusado de alta traición el ex
dictador termina exiliado en Dubai y en
2019 condenado a muerte en ausencia
en junio de 2022 su familia anunció que
padecía una rara enfermedad
falleció este domingo por la mañana en
un hospital de Dubai a la edad de 79
años